welcome back now if focusing on your
finances is one of your top priorities
in the new year i checked in with the
clark county credit union the sponsors
of this next segment to get some tips
check it out craig welcome back
thank you rocky good to see you good to
see you too it is now time to start
thinking about our new year's
resolutions especially financially
during this time so what are you seeing
out there when do people's financial new
year's resolutions start to fall off
well they start out gun hoe at the
beginning and typically a couple of
weeks in they start to wane off of it a
bit of course so how is the clark county
credit union here for us to help us
sustain that goal all year round
the easiest way to stick your financial
resolution is to have a plan and we have
several useful tips to help keep you on
track first is set everything up an
automatic payment your utilities your
rent your mortgage your car payment even
your savings if you do this you don't
have to worry about late payments and
your great payment history helps to
improve your credit
who very good advice and what other
advice would you give us
there's an old saying out with the old
and in with the new and that holds true
for a budget as well toss out that old
retired budget and create a new fresh
one that matches your current situation
for example during covet a lot of us
during the shutdown probably signed up
for a lot of those streaming services
and now that we don't have to be at home
as much we may not be using all of those
so that's a good time to redirect those
funds towards your financial goals like
paying down credit card debt or building
up your savings
okay and speaking of savings how do we
do that how do we build up our savings
as our new year's resolution
i think the easiest way to do that is
through direct deposit pay yourself
first also some of your other
resolutions may help with this you made
you make uh have a resolution to quit
smoking or to stop eating at fast food
restaurants so much you can redirect
those funds to your savings goals
and also savings can be fun you can make
a game out of it we'll call a match game
we take this one week every month and
every purchase you make match that
purchase to your that dollar amount to
your savings account or put a cap on it
and every time you make a purchase that
week throw a few dollars in savings and
if you're fortunate enough to get a
raise in the next year you can uh apply
a portion of that to your automatic
saving goals all these tips combined can
really make a difference in your savings
balance i love that and if you make it a
game that's a great way to get the kids
involved start teaching them early right
absolutely yeah you can make those big
thermometers and can color them in as
you hit certain goals and the kids can
do that and it makes it for the whole
family oh that's a good idea too okay so
what other tools do you guys have um at
clark county credit union for families
to keep on track
yeah the best tool is direct deposit and
then we also have other free financial
tools on our website we have a
debt calculator a budget calculator one
we have a debt payoff coach we have a
calculator for savings goals we also
have
some specialty savings accounts like a
christmas club account and a vacation
club account and to open an account with
clark county credit you need to take
advantage of all of these
programs and more you can visit us at
ccculv.org
or give us a call at 702-228-2228
we would love to help you stick your
financial resolutions
thank you clark county credit union for
sponsoring that segment give them a call
at
702-228-2228 or visit
ccculv.org and that's where you'll find
their free financial education tools
all right new year's eve